Good morning, Hank. It's Wednesday.
When did my house get so nice?!?
Oh right this isn't my house, this is a hotel room in the great city of Chicago, Illinois
where I am with David Levithan because we are on tour for Will Grayson, Will Grayson.
Shmancy hotel is shmancy
So Hank, there's this amazing tumblr that nerdfighters wrote called "effyeah nerdfighters" (Link in the dooblydoo)
And in the last day a lot of tumblrs - tumblrs? tumbleens? tumbloons?
Tumblees? Tumbleepoos? Tumbleepoos.
A lot of tumbleepoos have been uploading pictures of themselves holding "Will Grayson, will grayson"
But because of the mirroring of digital images that used to make it so hard for me to figure out how to point to the dooblydoo
it appears many people are not uploading pictures of themselves with the book called "Will Grayson, will grayson"
But instead with a book called "Nosyarg Lliw, nosyarg lliw"
Which, it belatedly occurs to me, would have been a great title.
If we write a sequel it's gonna be called "Nosyarg Lliw, nosyarg lliw"
So last night was the first event of the tour, Hank. It was great - 2 things I have to tell you.
First, there was a stormtrooper.
Not a Nazi stormtrooper, as Star Wars stormtrooper.
There were also a lot of people wearing THIS which is odd because it's hard to focus
on what you're saying when there's a pedophilic pizza loving version of yourself staring back at you
Oh! Oh AND check this out
DUN DUN DUNNNNNN
Nerdfighter: "Yeah, it's pretty awesome."
John: French the llama!
Oh and apropos of nothing, here's David and me outside of Frenchy's
John: Here we are!
David: Here we are!
John: At Frenchy's!
David: Viva the Frenchy's
John: Only funny if you've read the book
So speaking of which, your video on Monday (which by the way I loved)
made me think about the googlization of information in the contemporary world
I long thought that Google was technically making us stupider as individuals because
because the internal hard drive inside of our heads is not as needed anymore
because we have these massive external hard drives that Google can index
Like, for instance, when I was a kid I know the phone numbers of ALL my friends.
...don't be mean. That's not fair, I had friends!
Imaginary friends can have imaginary phone numbers okay??
Jeez, but anyway I knew dozens of imaginary phone numbers, now I know like... four phone numbers
because I have this amazing external hard drive that stores all the phone numbers I want.
And I've been thinking lately, Hank that one of the things long-form narratives, like novels, do is they help us to
arrange lots of information into a story.
Right, because it's much easier to remember things in a narrative than it is to remember random dislocated facts
But now that we have these external hard drives that are so good at remembering random facts, we no longer
need to organize information narratively in order to trick our crappy hard drives into remembering it.
And, Hank, I worry that as we spend more time on the Internet
By the way, Internet, I'm not trying to hurt your feelings here, you know I love you
Now, don't - don't mad at me, I - I know you're listening
(whispers): you're always listening
I worry that we will lose interest in, and think we're losing our need for those long-form narratives
that have so long been a huge part of what it means to be a person.
Now, Hank, that worries me partly because my job is writing those long-fom narratives
but it also worries me for other reasons.
But nerdfighters, I'm interested to know if you find it harder to read books these days.
I know that sometimes I do.
Obviously, I love books, but sometimes even when I'm enjoying a book I find myself putting it down to look at
the flashy flashy lights of the Internet.
So, nerdfighters, again I hope you like "Will Grayson, will grayson", hope to see a lot of you on tour
And, Hank, I will see you on Friday.